earlier in the show I talked to you
about the tapes the tapes that may exist
or may not exist here's Donald Trump
Arendt addressing the existence of those
tapes just the other day and you seem to
be hinting that there are recordings of
those converse I'm not hinting anything
I'll tell you about it over a very short
period of time okay okay do you have a
question here when will you tell us
about the report fairly short period of
time oh you're going to be very
disappointed when you hear the end so
don't worry John do you have a question
for the president soon it's been a long
time since these tapes were first
mentioned the house Intel committee has
given Donald Trump a book until June
23rd to release the tapes if they exist
this entire tapes thing might seem
trivial but it's not because either
Donald Trump hinted at tapes that don't
exist
to intimidate James Comey and he should
come clean about that lie and and that
is a type of intimidation or there are
tapes and they should be released so
that we can hear what was said and what
wasn't said in the meeting it will clear
up what Donald Trump says were lies from
James Comey just give us the tapes and
we'll listen to what he said and if that
tweet was just intended to intimidate
James Comey it completely backfired
because during the testimony James Comey
said lordy I hope there are tapes that
exactly right
I mean speaking among among friends here
it's hard to believe that the tapes if
they exist will be released and they
will reveal that Comey is a liar Comey
spent the majority of his 30 plus year
career in law enforcement testified
under oath in front of a Senate
subcommittee in testimony that hundreds
of millions of people will at least see
clips or reports of knowing that it's
possible that there are tapes which
could prove that he's lying if he
chooses to lie if anyone understands how
bad it could be to lie in those
circumstances it would be James Comey
who would realize I could end up in
prison and there's a possibility that
there are tapes
I just don't think Comey was lying it's
also pretty ludicrous how the White
House is playing coy when it comes to if
there are tapes or not yeah they would
be the ones to know no one else they
would be the ones who made the
recordings do
I believe there are tapes I don't
believe that there are tapes I know that
Trump has a history of recording people
in the business world but I believe that
the tapes thing was to intimidate James
Comey which is actually worse than the
recording of the meeting which by the
way would violate Washington DC law it's
possible Trump recorded the meetings but
you know I would imagine that in New
York New York is a one-party consent
state for recording meaning as long as
one of the people being recorded knows
there is a recording it's legal
Washington DC is a two-party consent
state meaning that both parties being
recorded needs to know about it or it's
illegal now you could say Donald Trump
doesn't give a flying you-know-what
about whether he's breaking the law or
not
however Trump is not technologically
savvy and you would imagine that if
Trump asked for oval office meeting
recordings again the phone system is
another thing if he's asking for the
meetings to be recorded I would imagine
someone might say that is criminal it
violates the wiretapping laws don't do
it so my view is I don't believe that
there are tapes here well just so you
know I am recording this in case your
prediction goes sour yes record now by
all means I'm okay with that and yeah
Massachusetts many states our two-party
consent States and it becomes
complicated when you're calling from a
one-party consent state to a two-party
consent state I believe federal
wiretapping laws take precedents there
although not really relevant here I
don't believe there are tapes I believe
it was an intimidate or tactic and I'm
very curious what Trump will ultimately
tell us about this and many people on
our reddit discussion forum are talking
about this I encourage you to join us
there at david pakman.com slash reddit
today's program sponsored in part by
movement watches movement watches was
started by two broke college kids that
wanted stylish watches couldn't afford
them they'd go into the department
stores and the watches they liked were
four to five hundred dollars so instead
using crowdfunding similar to the David
Pakman show I might add using
crowdfunding to grow these two broke
college kids developed a watch brand
that has really nice looking watches
starting at just 95 dollars
a fraction of what department stores
will typically charge you the
revolutionary pricing the classic design
the quality construction it's led to
over 500,000 watches being sold in over
a hundred and sixty countries I have a
couple movement watches now and wherever
I go
I notice my friends can barely pay
attention to what I'm saying
not because I'm being boring although
sometimes that's the case but because
they're distracted by the watch and
everybody said what is that watch I
checked in the other day at my dentist's
office and as I was signing in the
receptionist said I really like that
watch what is that watch so I encourage
you to step up your watch game see why
people across the world love movement
watches go to M V M t.com slash Pakman
which is of course PA que ma n get 15%
off today plus free shipping plus free
returns movement watches make great
gifts maybe for your dad Father's Day
coming up movement is the place to shop
nvm t-dot-com
slash Pakman